[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
عاملين ايه الاول انا مبسوط جدا ان انا
موجود معكم النهارده مين علاج طبيعي في
الناس الموجوده
[موسيقى]
طيب
انا الاول مبسوط جدا والله انا موجود معكم
النهارده انا اللي ما تعرفهوش ان انا اصلا
بالمنيا يعني انا اصلا من المنيا اساسا بس
مش من المنيا المحافظه يعني
فاول ثاني مره اجيب حياتي الميديا
المقاوله نفسها ان شاء الله النهارده
جايين نتكلم في توبك يمكن عشان يفيد الناس
كلها مش بس علاج طبيعي هنتكلم على 5 يعني
خمس دعائم او عمدان او ركاز للنجاح
الحاجات دي كلها الخمس الكويس دي ممكن
طبعا كل واحد يكون له وجهه نظر في الموضوع
مختلفه بس انا من خلال تجربتي ورحلتي
اخترت لكم من خمس حكايات دول ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله التوفيق يكون مفيد وتحاول ان
انت تطبقه بشكل عملي باذن الله لو خدت
المعلومات دي وركزت فيها تفرق معي
طيب الاول اعرفكم بنفسي ما عرفنيش انا
اسمي حازم طارق احمد خليك كل التعليق
طبيعي جامعه القاهره 2019
من
سي سي اللي هي مدرب شخص معتمد يعني من
اكاديميه الطب الرياضيات الامريكيه وحاليا
ماجستير علاج طبيعي جامعه القاهره عظام
يعني سكن
بعمل فيديوهات على اليوتيوب تمام
اعرفكم بقى على الحاجه اللي انا بعملها
وهي مصر مصر دي انا بداتها في علاج طبيعي
وانا بدرس لسه كنت في سنه ثالثه الترم
الثاني
كان الهدف منها يعني ان احنا نشارك مع
الناس الحاجات اللي بنبدا ندرسها بشكل عام
ونطبقها بشكل عملي حاليا الحمد لله على
يوتيوب 3 مليون 300 الف متابع تقريبا او
اكثر شويه ومليون شويه على الفيسبوك وشويه
ناس كده على الانستجرام طبعا كلهم على
راسي جدا جدا
ويعني لولا الناس اللي قاعده والناس اللي
احنا بنقدم لها مكناش الحمد لله
طيب هنبدا بقى نتكلم على
طيب مين عنده تصارع عن النجاح انا عايز حد
يبقى عنده سعر النجاح يرفع حد يعرف ان
نجاح اصلا يعني 100 شخص الناجح ها لو حد
عايز حاجه تبقى انت لو حد عايز
بيحقق الانجازات ممتاز يعني الناجح هو
بيحقن انجازات حد عنده
ممتاز يعني بيعمل حاجه بتبسطه ولما
بيعملها بيتبسط بيعتبر ناجح جميل جدا
ممتاز طب انت بالنسبه لك النجاح ايه اسمك
ايه مؤمن انت مؤمن نجاح بالنسبه لك ايه
دلوقتي حلو حلو حلو قوي هو قال دلوقتي
يعني معنى كده ان ممكن النجاح نفسه في وقت
ثاني يكون لي
تعريف
سنه كام
قولي عليك طبيعي
طب ممتاز جدا يعني ممكن يكون النجاح
بالنسبه للطالب ان هو يجيب ايه كويس
ان النجاح له تعريفات مختلفه طيب انا
هستعرض شويه صور ناس يقال عليهم ناجحين في
المجتمع وعايز اسمع رايكم مين ده مثلا
صلاح صلاح
عايز اسمع كله يشارك ها ناجح طيب هو صلاح
بيعمل ايه
صلاح بيلعب يا جماعه
والله صلاح بيلعب بيلعب كوره كم واحد
بيلعب كوره هنا
انا بحب العب كوره جدا بس بلعب كوره
بعرف العب والله بيقولوا يعني بس ما حدش
قال لي انت ناجح ولا بتعمل اي حاجه ولا
الكلام ده بس بالنسبه لصلاح الموضوع مختلف
الموضوع مش بس تحول لنجاح عادي ده نجاح
جماهيري لما تلاقي ناس في انجلترا بتقعد
تنادي باسمه فاكيد الشخص ده ناجح بشكل او
با
خر يعني مين ده يعرف
غني
واحنا صغيرين غني ده مثلا لو سمعت عنه في
وسط ووريته مثلا لواحد في مصر عادي خالص
مثلا بنقول سواق ميكروباص مثلا هيعرفوا
يعني في الغالب لا بس محمد صلاح
الميكروباص ده هيعرفه طب لو رحت الهند
ووريت محمد صلاح للهنود وريت غاندي الهنود
مين هيعرفوا اكتر بجد ممكن في الهند
بالنسبه لهم حد واو اللي جاب النجاح من
غيره تمام مين ده
صح طيب يعني
طيب محمد رمضان بيعمل ايه
بيمثل صح طيب هو التمثيل ده لحد ذاته حاجه
حلوه ولا وحشه
احنا بنتكلم طبعا من اي منظور ولا اي حاجه
خالص بنتكلم بشكل عام هي حاجه بتتعمل يعني
يمكن مثلا لو قعدنا نمثل دلوقتي على بعض
ممكن اي حد يكون بيمقع مثلا بيمثل بيضحك
على الثاني هو بيمثل برده تمام بس محمد
رمضان كارقام وكان مشاهدات وكشهره وكمعرفه
يعني مقصر الدنيا المفروض طيب هل انت
نفسك ياللي قاعد دلوقتي
بتحتاج ممكن واحد يقول اه ممكن واحد يقول
لا احترف وجهه نظري ان كانت ايه بس يعني
في فئه
كبيره في رمضان
ضاره اكتر مفاجاه مثلا ممكن ناس تانيه
شايفها شخص ناجح جدا ويا ريت تبقى ربع
محمد رمضان وانت حاطط وحاسس واعداء النجاح
صح طيب فده مثال برده تاني مين ده
تمام اصل الضحكه في مصر
طيب
مين شاف اللي خلي الكوميدي نجح
ما حدش شافه صح مع الكوميدي ده ما بين
2018 ل 2021 تقريبا كان عامل ارقام محمد
رمضان ما كانش عاملها مثلا يمكن
وقت ما تخبطش في خليل كوميدي كده في مره
لا في الغالب يعني الجيد بتاعنا كله
تقريبا
نجاح على فكره يعني هو من حيث الارقام ومن
حيث ممكن الفلوس ومن حيث الشهره يعني مثلا
الحوار ده من من برنامج هو كان عامله مع
حد واخد فلوس عشان يوقف معاه في البرنامج
هم اكيد مش هيدي فلوس وهو ما بيعملش حاجه
صح فهو بشكل او باخر ممكن يكون ناجح بس
يمكن مش بتحبه فعشان كده انت مش مستنظف
الموضوع يعني طيب سيدنا عمرو بن العاص شخص
ناجح ولا مش ناجح
كل ما يقول ناجح جامد كده اللي هو طيب هو
سيدنا عمرو بن العاص انا موجود نظري شخص
ناجح جدا شخص اي حد مسلم قاعد في القاعه
دي ومصري عايش يعني في ميزان حسنات الراجل
ده ربنا يرضى عنه يعني تمام هل كتير يعرف
يعني لو سالنا في الجيل بتاعنا دلوقتي
تعرف عمرو بن اوس تعرف عمرو رمضان ممكن
يكون
فهل ده
برده انت جاوب
سيدنا نوح مين يعرف سيدنا نوح طيب العريس
سيدنا نوح عارف ان في القران وما امن معه
الا قليل سيدنا نوح ده من الخمسه يعني من
اجمد الرسل يعني
ركزوا ان ربنا بعث انبياء كتير تقوم صفوه
البشر من ضمن الانبياء في رسل ربنا استقام
بالرساله من ضمن الرسل دول في خمسه اللي
هم اعلى رسل منزله عند ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
سيدنا نوح منهم وما امن معه الا قليل يعني
50 60 واحد ما يكملوش 100 وقعد في قومه
يدعوهم 950 سنه تقريبا تمام
فما عندوش غير خمسين متخيل يعني
هيبقى عنده خمسين فوق بس تخيل يعني انا
عندي سيدنا نوح تخيل بس انا طبعا انا جنبي
سيدنا
في اي حته تمام فسيدنا نوح ناجح ولا مش
ناجح ناجح بشهاده ربنا سبحانه وتعالى وانت
خايف يعني اللي شاهد له بالنجاح هو ربنا
فاللي انا عايز اقوله ايه ان الامثله دي
كلها امثله ممكن تكون ناجحه فاول بري
احنا بنت
لان الموضوع ممكن يختلف جدا النجاح لو
سالنا كل واحد في القاعه هنا هيرد مختلفه
النجاح ممكن يكون بالنسبه لك انت حاجه
ممكن بالنسبه لواحد ثاني حاجه ثانيه فلو
وعدت تقارن نجاحك مثلا بنجاح محمد رمضان
ما انت ناجح لو انت مثلا مش اتجاهاتك زيه
لو قعدت تفتكر نجاحك من نجاح واحد ثاني
عمره ما هتحس ان انت او ان انت عامل حاجه
كويسه ليه لان النجاح نفسه ليه معنى ليك
فقبل ما تفكر في فكر معنى النجاح انت
بالنسبه لك برامج
تاني عندنا وتاني عمود في النجاح من وجهه
نظري هو
طيب مين فينا دايما فاكر ان النجاح له
علاقه مرتبطه بالشخصيه يعني في ناس اتولد
وناجحين وفي ناس اتولدوا حاجات تانيه مين
مين جواه كده يعني مصدق حاجه زي كده يرفع
ايده
خالص والله
ممتاز حلو اللي انا بقوله بقى مين شايف ان
الذكاء والشخصيه والمواهب اللي ربنا اداه
للشخص هي اللي بتخليني نجح او لا انا واحد
من الناس يعني كنت بحاول اقول غير كده
ودائما اقول
العقليه العقليه دي طيب ان انت ممكن يكون
ملكش يعني ممكن
ممتاز حلو نقطه كويسه بس اللي انا عايز
اقوله ان انا مثلا شخصيا في فتره في حياتي
انا مثلا بصنف نفسي كحد مش مش اذكى واحد
في الدنيا بس والله الحمد لو جينا عملنا
مسابقه دلوقتي انا اكتر واحد هتعب وانا
متاكد من ده عشان اوصل للي انا عايزه ها
بص لو بتذاكر انت ساعه وما شاء الله بتلم
المنهج الماده كلها ثلاث ايام عشان نلم
اللي انتكره تمام
ده بشكل عام كنت دائما جوايا حاسس ان يعني
ايه من فتره في حياتي يعني ان لا ده في
ناس اتولدت ناجحه او عندها المقومات اللي
بتخليها ناجحه وفي ناس يعني مهما عملت
مستوى النجاح لتوصله ليه سقف معين مش
هتعدي الكلام ده طبعا الكلام ده غلط تماما
يا جماعه الكلام ده عالي تماما عن الصحه
يعني النجاح اه الشخصيه بتفرح ولو انت
ربنا جمع فيك الحاجتين الذكاء الفطري او
ان انت قدراتك العقليه والحاجات الذكائك
ده الذكاء نفسه انواع يعني في انواع كتير
لو عرفت توظف نوع بتاع الذكاء بتاعك فمجال
شغلك او مجال حياتك او اللي انت بتعمله اه
فعلا هتبقى انت بقى من الناس اللي انعم
عليك يعني وتبقى حاجه جامده جدا لكن
الاساس في النجاح هو
الشغل العمل تمام يعني بنقول ان انت كتير
قوي فينا اوفر فينكر بيقعد يفكر كثير
وكميره افكار انا واحد من الناس دي مين
بعد الساعه 12:00 بيقعد بقى يفكر بقى كده
ايه مين بيحب البيزنس في الشغل والحاجات
ديت طيب ماشي يا ايه بيجيلك افكار بعد نص
الليل
انا بقى ايه هعمل الشركه ساعه المونتاج
وبتاعه البي اي وهعمل تطبيق وبص اول سنه
هعمل مليون دولار والسنه الثانيه وبعدين
تلاقي نفسك صاحي على راح الكليه صح بيحصل
فاحنا بنفكر كتير قوي لكن ما بناخدش خطوات
تقريبا معظم الناس كده لكن دائما افتكر ان
اكشن لودر يعني الافعال اللي بتتكلم الناس
كلها بتقول يعني اي حد بيقول بس دائما
الشخص الناجح بجد
واحده بتنجح اصلا فلو قعدت بقى ان انت
ناجح بكميه الافكار بتجيلك فانت اكيد مش
مش بتفكر بطريقه صحيحه يعني تمام
وعشان تنجح اصلا لازم يعني انت طبيعي عشان
توصل للف
كره وتنجح وتعمل الكلام ده كله لازم تمر
لحظات فشل فنصيحتي دي
افشل كتير افشل بسرعه هتنجح اسرع ان شاء
الله
ده ياخدنا للبرر اللي بعد كده وهي وركن
نيويكتورز لسه كنا قايلين في النقطه اللي
فاتت ان الشخصيه او بتلعب
زي ما احمد قال
طريقه تعاطيك مع الحياه يعني طريقه تعاملك
مع المواقف وده لحسن الحظ شيء احنا نقدر
نظبطه يعني حاجه ربنا خلقنا ومدينا
الاختيارات
وانت اللي ممكن تهدى شويه وتفكر تقول
الموضوع مش مستاهل انت ممكن تفكر تقول انا
عندي دلوقتي محاضره انا خدتها النهارده
الذاكرها النهارده
ولو عملت كده كل مره عارف ان انت مثلا في
الشهر الاخير اللي قبل الامتحانات هتلم
الدنيا وتطلع الاول هتدخله وانت نفس الشخص
برضو اللي عارف انت لو اجلت هتيجي تزنق
نفسك
وفي الاخر تعمل ايه تنجح بقى ويحصل بقى اي
حاجه خلاص تمام فالموضوع كله له علاقه
بالشخصيه بتاعتك فاشتغل على شخصيتك تمام
لكن كتير مننا بيشتغل مع شخصيته وبيتكلم
معاه بشكل صحيح يعني مين شايف ان كل شخص
له مميزات وعيوب
صح طيب طب مين شايف ان عنده عيوب
طيب انا بقى ما بحبش اسميها عيوب يعني انت
لو سميت الحاجه اللي في شخصيتك دي عيب
خلاص شكرا انت كده حكمت على نفسك ان انت
قابلت العيب ده اللي هو خدني على عيبي كده
زي ما بيقولوا وخلاص مش هتطوره انا دائما
بحب اسميها ان هي قصور يعني دائما مع نفسك
خليكي جامد يعني انك ما تقولش الفاظ ممكن
تضايق نفسك من نفسك فخليني اقول مثلا
الشخص شجاع حلو صح مين بيحب الشجاع
ها مين يحب شجاع طيب مين يحب متسرع
طيب على فكره الشجاع متسرع
يعني الشجاع متسرع لو مخدتش بالي لان صفه
الشجاعه بشكل عام هي وجهات عمله واحده
معصبه التسرع شخص الشجاع ده هو شخص مندفع
شخص ممكن مقدام بيحاول يعمل حاجات كثيره
فده بيخليك متسرع فعشان كده هاجي للشخص
[ضحك]
طيب مين بيحب يبقى جبان
اكيد لا طب مين بيحني اكيد كلنا صح فدائما
لما تيجي تقول ما تقولش مثلا انا مش جريء
ده انا مش عارف ايه لا ده انا متاني بس
نقول لشخص الشجاع ايه تانى الشخص المتاني
في القرارات السريعه مثلا تجيب تيشرت مش
لازم تقعد تفكر نص ساعه البرتقالي ولا لسه
هيحصل حاجه يعني تمام
واهم حاجه برده تشتغل على الاسكيلز بتاعك
لان الاسكيلز بتاعتك او المهارات هي فعلا
هتخليك شخص ناجح احنا
بنحتاج عشان عندنا مها
رات صح تخيل
كهربائي وحلاق ومش عارف ايه وكده مش
هتحتاج حد صح فكل ما هتزود الاسكيلز
والمهارات بتاعتك فرصه
المجال
يعني النجاح عمره عمره مكان سقف واي حد
فاكر ان اي حد نجح حتى من الناس اللي احنا
ممكن ما نحترمش نجاحهم دول الموضوع جبطه
حظ او الموضوع جاله كده بشكل بسيط ففكر
تاني الموضوع صعب جدا الشاعر كان بيقول
ايه لا تحسبن المجد لا تمرا انت اكله لم
تبلغ الم
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
ده النجاح ايا كان المجال دايما المجال
يبقى صح بقى دائما تختار المجال وتحدد
وانت عايز تعمل ايه بالظبط عشان التعب ده
كله ما يروحش بالصعب ان هو يعني اي حد
تلاقيه بيدرس معاك ويقول لك ايه يا عم ده
الناس دلوقتي خلاص بقى وده بي
عملوا حتى على فكره اللي بيعمله مثلا مش
قادر خالص ومحتوى ممكن اسميه مبتزل مثلا
او حاجه الناس دي بتتعب برده بس يعني ممكن
بياخدوا القيمه اكبر بكثير قوي من الناس
بتتعب اكتر لكن القيمه دائما
مش قصاد التعب قوي يعني مفيش مش ايه مش
بالبورش كده مع بعض مش مش لا مختلف شويه
تمام بس النجاح صعب لازم لو عايز تاخد
طيب لازم تعمل حسابك ان انت هتتنفخ بس
فلازم تبقى مستعد للدائك
رقم خمسه بتاعتنا
هيست اه النقطه دي مهمه جدا جدا تمام من
واحنا صغيرين للاسف اللي في الكالتشر
المصريه والمجتمع ايه زي ابن خالتك وزي
بنت خالتك وزي ابن عمتك وزي مش عارف مين
وابن الجيران والناس صح احنا من ساعه ما
بنتولد يا جماعه في للاسف يعني نظام
التعليم اللي احنا موجودين فيه للاسف
بتكلم على التعليم
قبل كده طيب ماشيين في الخ
لاط يعني يلا يا كبرت خلاص هتدخل كي جي
وبعدين هتدخل بقى ابتدائي وبعدين هتدخل
مواد زي كلنا زي بعض وبيتم الحكم وتقييمك
بفتك الدراسيه على فكره يعني انت خلاص
يعني عندك نوع من الانثال الجنس اللي هو
الاي كيو مثلا او نوع ذكاء معين بيخليك
قوه حفظ عاليه
خالص ناجح لو انت ما عندكش مواعيد من
الذكاء فانت بتبقى شخص فاشل وبتقتنع ان
انت تبقى فاشل وتفضل ايه تقارن نفسك
بنفس درجات عاليه
طب يا جماعه هو في ايه وانا فاش طب انا
اعمل ايه طيب اقطع شرايين طب ولا اعمل ايه
ما هو الموضوع مش هينفع صح ما تقارنش
نجاحك ونجاح حد دي بقى نقطه تبقى عارفها
حاول دائما تدعم في نفسك عن طريق التجرب
حاجات كثيره قوي هتعرف انت كويس وربنا
مميز كل واحد فينا بحاجه اكيد مفيش حد مش
مميز كل واحد زي ما له بصمه مختلفه هو
مميز بشكل او باخر تمام فحاول دائما
[موسيقى]
حد ثاني لان انت لك حياتك ومسلكك وط
ريقتك واحد مثلا افترض تخرج قبلك ده بدا
شغل قبلك اتجوز قبلك خلف قبلك
كود اكتر منك هو معناه ان هو واخد في
الحته دي اكتر شويه دلوقتي ممكن انت في
حته ثانيه لو ركزت مع حيطه هتلاقيك متفوق
في حته اشتغل على اللي عندك وما تقارنش
نجاحك وفي الاخر برضو اينشتاين حاجه جامده
جدا الجمله يعني منسوبه اليه ومش عارف هي
صحيحه ولا مش قوي بس معناه بالعربي يعني
اتكلم عربي ازاي ابدا
بيقول الجميع لكن اذا حكمت على قدره سمكه
في تساقط شجره ستعيش حياتها كلها وهي غبيه
تمام صح
سمكه بتعوم يعني حطها في البحر هتلاقيها
بتعوم طب بتقول لي بقى يلا السمك خليها
تتصدق
غلط يا جماعه انا مش مظبوطه يعني فلو مش
مكان
ك روح مكان ثاني غير تمام وفي الاخر
زياده يعني للناس اللي قعدت لحد الاخر
المركزه اثناء طولت عليك شويه
دايما يكون عندك قدوه قدوه دي هتفرق معاك
كتير جدا جدا في حياتك ايا كان المجال
اللي انت عايزه شوف التوب
وحاول ان انت
اعمل ده كان زمان بيسموها ايه الاسطى
والصبي تمام لازم يبقى فيه الفكره دي حتى
لو جوه دماغك تمام
ما عرفتش تعمل ده بشكل في عندنا سوشيال
ميديا والناس بتشارك كل حاجه مع بعض
دلوقتي لازم يبقى عندك
طبعا
تمام
كل حاجه بس في مجالك انت حاول دايما يبقى
ليك مرجعيه شخصي كبير كده وتبص له ده
اختصر عليك وقت كتير جدا مجهود كبير جدا
خبره هو اكتسبها في ثواني وهتوصل لاحلام
اللي هو معرفش تمام وفي الاخر خالص اللي
عايز اقوله ان انت في الاخر ما عليك الا
الساعه ربنا بيقول ايه وقال ليس للانسان
الا ما سعى تمام فكل اللي عليك ان انت
تسعه وتعمل اللي عليك وربنا نفسه اللي هو
انت بتعمل كل ده المفروض عشانه بجد نيتك
هيحاسبك على السعي ده سعيد كتير عند ربنا
ساعات قليل حتى لو الموضوع ارقام في
الدنيا مال كبير اكيد برده ده ملوش نتيجه
شكرا
[تصفيق]